[Music]
Amir shat how are you how are you doing
our very first session
yes indeed I see your you chose a nice
background of the Bay Area where are you
are you in NASA or Star Trek no Star
Trek Star Trek it's the first
[Music]
series all right Amir what are you are
you an entrepreneur a product manager a
an engineer I I can't even follow
anymore so I'm an engineer by trade uh
now I do more product um basically I've
done about 15 years in corporate uh
companies uh building developer
platforms and working with developers on
developer platforms and now I've retired
to the startup life and do uh
Investments uh and I also co-found a
startup so you retired to the startup
life okay I like that yes whoever told
you the startup life is the hardest has
haven't been uh VPN big companies it's
uh it's not as easy as it sounds okay so
now when you say big companies I mean
you're talking about Google Microsoft
slack
twitch yes uh yeah I started at uh
started a few startups uh sold one
crashed another two yeah then uh then
moved uh to Microsoft to work on
SharePoint and on WPF with developers um
then went to Google actually working
with your father uh on launching a
campus uh here um and then was asked to
move to the states to manage Google
startup program uh out of develop
relations that was a lot of fun uh at
the end of my time at Google I managed
all of uh the developer Outreach
programs so Google developer groups uh
developer experts women in technology
and the startup program um and then I
joined the small startup again called
slack um and yeah we were 90 people at
the time so you were tiny okay yeah we
were kind of small I remember a full
floor empty and they said yeah one day
we'll fill this entire floor and we're
like yeah right never going to happen um
and we had 50 developers when we
launched the platform and two and a half
years later we had 250,000 developers
and the company was 2,000 so that was
that was insane um and then two and a
half years later uh Amazon has reached
out to me um and asked me to uh join a
company that they've acquired called
twitch um and I was the VP of the
platform uh the API platform there um
and a year ago I've uh basically retired
to the startup flight so uh enjoying
myself made a few Angel Investments um
and um co-founded reshuffle wonderful
okay so how many how many years are you
would you say you're very very deep into
Tech and products and consumers oh wow
uh I would say 99 so that's 21 years 21
years okay so give me like you know the
the your your two cents after 21 years
you know I mean every every kid on the
Block does a startup and tries to
revolutionize Healthcare and payments
and and whatever and I mean how do how
are you how do you not develop some sort
of cynicism after 21 years to all these
different initiatives how how do you
remain
excited because you see success right um
think of when people try to fly for a
very long time people thought and
dreamed of flying but for there we
didn't see any success for a very long
time if we were to say okay man can fly
that's it we wouldn't be having our the
things experiences that we have not
today because nobody can fly but in
general um so it it's it's very
different and the tech world where you
see success and you see success
happening very fast so I think we're in
a unique moment in history where the uh
the moment from ideation into success is
is amazing so I'm I've thought about a
night project a month ago about
something and now I'm going to launch it
very soon around like Co and helping
people do things around that so um you
can easily uh move to from ideation to
implementation and that's that's amazing
that means that you can lower your
cynicism because cynicism is a tool that
helps you judge whether an idea is good
or not but once you have this rapid
development you don't need to judge you
can see for yourself right so if a bad
if I hear something that it's a bad idea
I don't necessarily want to tell the
people that it's a bad idea because they
might need to learn or I might be wrong
so I I remove judgment and it's a much
better way because reality is the best
judge of everything right so I mean you
you've been it's very rare when somebody
gets to go through you know so so many
of the huge companies that anybody would
dream to work at one day and and you
have the privilege of of seeing
internally how how so many of them
operate are there are they are do they
operate the same way I mean when you're
talking about 100,000 people employees
you would imagine that they would sort
of converge to the same best
practices no so there are things that
are similar for example um Facebook and
Google are very similar in their hiring
process um promotion is done in a very
similar way between Facebook and Amazon
uh but every company has a very very
unique uh aspect that makes it its DNA
very different so for example uh at
Google uh Pro Promotions are done by
committee so I used to work in one of
those committees and you go and you get
12 packets just like a book that tells
you why this person needs to be promoted
and you have a discussion for a few a
few hours uh to talk about whether a
person needs to be promoted or not and
it's not promoted by your manager it's
promoted by your peers so it's a very
unique way to get promoted at uh Amazon
decision making is very very unique you
don't need to get everybody's approval
you only need to get one person's
approval so the company optimizes for
Rapid decision- making and ex and Rapid
execution interesting it's it is okay if
someone else is uh building something
similar to what you're building we
because competition is okay at Amazon uh
so in different and of course Facebook
is famous for uh move fast and break
things which is very very different than
Google which is don't break it right so
I think even even Mark changed it a few
years ago when he realized that it's a
little bit exactly yeah uh um it's also
if you want another interesting thing
that is different between companies is
who's the strong organization in the
company so at Google engineering is very
strong so when I wanted to change
something in Gmail because it didn't
look the way I wanted it I had to go and
find the engineer who's working on the
projects wow at stack for example
designers are very strong so everything
needs to go through design and look
amazing and feel amazing
interesting um so in different companies
there's different focuses on who's
making the decisions okay so I'm here
let's play a game Let's fast forward
four years into the future and reshuffle
as a thousand person
company and and uh which type of uh
future do you see is this the future
that you're seeing
uh is this the future that you're
seeing well I'll let you decide on that
so what how does how does reshuffle look
with a thousand people I mean what what
what are some of the most crucial items
that you take and you
forgo so I think the the most important
thing um that you need to do is solidify
the DNA of your company what is it mean
to be and it's usually uh good
entrepreneurs start by writing the
principles of their company what are the
core principles and how can you keep the
DNA of the company growing for example
at at Slack we were doubling our size
for a certain duration every two weeks
so every two weeks we hired the amount
of people working in the company at the
time which is insane so how do you keep
the new people to have the same uh
experience and same uh virtues that that
you want to keep in the company right so
we were working with them and training
them and making sure that they know and
understand what does it mean to work at
at slack what does it mean for for
example EMP to your customers so knowing
that you're when a customer complains
about something you never say no it's
not a problem or we'll never fix it
you'll need to say hey it's broken and
I'm sorry and we'll we'll we'll work on
it until it's better right so things
like that are super important so what I
hope to have reshuffle uh be is an
amazing place to work at a place where
people can collaborate can be creative
can feel empowered um so every time I
think about ay and how it's success it
is successful I think about what are the
core tenants um that I want for these
companies and you can start start too
early so I've just worked with an
entrepreneur she's a ex Facebook and
she's now before she's even raising
money she's writing the core principles
of her company but obviously that
changes right your your principles
change over time you're just like you
can pivot your product you can pivot
your mission and your core values yeah
that's true true uh for example uh
Amazon has done a review of their core
values every couple of years they do uh
review of their core values and they
modify and change them uh and if you
look at what they've done about five
years ago is ADD Innovation because for
them until that point Innovation was
given because they were the innovators
in the in the company but what they've
seen is that Innovation was going down
because they were making they were like
the they it wasn't their bread and
butter anymore so they added that into
the mix of of changing the company so
yes a company needs to have a different
DNA as it goes uh as it
grows so now you're now you're an
entrepreneur and you're an investor at
the same time so at one so most of the
day you wear the hat of a of a of head
of product at a com at a small
startup um obviously and especially with
everything that's going on in the world
now which is especially crazy for
startups I can't even imagine and I'd
love to hear about that too but at the
same time then you're putting on your
hat and you're saying okay now I'm going
to invest my money in people like me who
are also trying to make it do you need
to Def to have sort of a double
personality for that how do you
differentiate between these
roles yeah it's it's pretty hard because
as a Founder you need to have a lot of
excitement yeah and as a as an investor
you need to have a little bit of
skepticism um and it's a you need to
have different personas I guess um what
I found is that you need to develop a
certain thesis in order to at least to
start to to think about investment and
the thesis that I had is how can I find
Founders that I know would be able to
execute well because I'm investing in a
very very early stage and I know the
company that I'm investing it will not
be the company that will grow at the end
because people pivot and people change
and companies change uh and and and my
company reshuffle has has pivoted a few
times but what I'm looking for is like
can this entrepreneur uh handle change
can they uh see that the that the
reality has changed can they see that
their product has not reached a c
product Market fit and know what to do
in order to change it so I'm more of
investing in people rather than
companies and I think when you're
founding uh when you're founding a
company when you're a founder or a CPO
it's basically the same because you're
investing in the people you're making a
a leap of faith because at the end of
the day your startup is nothing without
awesome people that make it awesome so
it's basically the same type of
investment only here I'm putting my
money and here I'm putting something
even more valuable when my startup which
is my
time one one thing that people don't
realize is that uh opening a startup is
a sevene year deal people uh think it's
yeah I'm going to make money and then I
move if you're a Founder you're there
for between five and seven years uh
until until you're successful so you
need to make sure that the people around
you are amazing that you really like to
work with them yeah no I mean that makes
a lot of sense do you do you often see
that you're almost looking for yourself
in the founders and you're trying to
look for people that have that and
you're comparing your own passion to
theirs because you're going through the
same process at the same time no I'm
looking for people who are much better
than
me I I think that um I always try to
find people who are much better than me
when I was hiring for my team at slack
um I was developer Relations number one
and I tried to fire myself from each of
my capabilities so the first person I
found was a much better uh technical
writer and the next person I found was
much better at uh uh working on
Partnerships um I do not want to find
people who are at my level I want to
raise the bar I want to be the most
stupid person in the room of the my
portfolio interesting so product
management H you've done it quite quite
a bit across the board what are some of
the pitfalls where where do people go
wrong but you know like the like the
weirdest things that just people don't
understand
uh the weirdest the the most common
thing is called the Ivory Tower syndrome
which is you sit in your freaking Ivory
Tower and you say this will be what's
good for the masses users will do this
will love that and you're like you're
you're stuck there and you're totally
disconnected from your actual audience
which usually doesn't even care about
your thoughts yeah right the most common
uh mistake that people the most common
problem that entrepreneurs and product
managers hit is is
indifference people see the product they
don't understand they don't care they
move on and the and and then the founder
or the product manager is like but I
build all this and you want it and so uh
being humble is the most important thing
you need to uh have empathy for your
customers you need to understand and
love your customers and you need to know
exactly what is their needs and then you
need to validate all your assumptions
because 90% of your assumptions are
wrong unless you're um Steve Jobs and
even Steve Jobs had multiple multiple
products that fail there was Apple ads
there was like if you look at all the
you can find in Google the list of
products that Steve Jobs started that
were a total failure yeah and it's very
insightful because even a person who we
all recognize as a great product leader
had multiple multiple assumptions that
were wrong so the most common Pitfall
for a uh PM is to have strong opinions
that are strongly held you have to have
strong opinions that are weakly held
saying hey this is my thesis on my
product but I'm willing and and love to
be proven wrong because then I can I can
uh change uh my thought process and make
my product better okay so another
thought game and one of the things that
I want to do is I want to build
something in a developing a area and try
to create a meaningful technological
product that improves people's lives now
let's say I'm trying to solve the
problem of of the lack of of good water
for drinking purifying water I don't
have a water problem I mean I can go and
drink here from the sink how so what can
I do as the as a product manager or as a
CEO so that I can empathize with with
people that are that I'm building the
product to that I'm I'm don't NE neily
am going to be a user myself which I'm
guessing is most the case that's a great
question uh very common Silicon Valley
problem right because in the Silicon
Valley luckily we have a lot of like
amenities and like people life here is
good yeah you're a freaking spaceship
now complain that that their Amazon
shipment was late by 20 minutes right
that's the biggest problem um but if you
look at companies that have done radical
things around building empathy to to
their their customers they were they
were very successful in those Endeavors
so for example Facebook has shipped
their entire team I don't remember if it
was to India their mobile team either to
India or to Africa to build their mobile
app there because they said like w if
you're on 4G that's not a problem to
have a very rich mobile app but try to
build a mobile app for the developer
countries while you're not in a
bandwidth when there's no bandwidth
sometimes when you have very spotty
connections so I would say if you if
you're trying to build something for
developer for developed countries when
there's white water shortage spend time
there like actually feel and be there um
the other thing is
interviews people don't do inter enough
interviews again another big product
problem
yeah I would say that uh as a rule of
thumb you need to interview your
customer different types of customers at
least once a week I meet with my
customers different customers all the
time at least once a week even after you
think you have the solution and you know
what you need to do all the time my uh
SVP at twitch said that I have to find
an advisor streamer somebody who's like
who whose job it is to use twitch and I
need to they need to be my uh rightwing
man interesting and I found someone and
they were so helpful in in thinking
through the product because the way I
was thinking about the product was very
different than the way they were
thinking about
the wow Amir H you need to go back to
running a company but H before we go
three words that describe
you three words that describe me wow um
bald I guess uh bald bald and
uh manager um risk lever I guess it's
two words I'll take it I'll take risk
lever totally I totally fail in this
test Amir thank you so much have a good
one stay safe and healthy